[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Micah is
in Washington DC he hi Michael what's
up hey Dave hey George thanks for taking
my call sure what's
up hey so a little bit about me I'm uh
24 I'm currently debt free um I make
$80,000 a year I am currently maxing out
my 401k and
Ira I want to buy a car that cost
$30,000 um however I'm I don't want to
get rid of my current car it would just
be a you know a play car it's it's a
sports car my question is is I have
30,000 in cash that I'm prepared to pay
for this car um I'm not sure if it's
better to put this in a different sort
of Investment Portfolio or if it would
be okay you know to to splurge and buy
this car oh I see I thought you were
calling the car an investment my face
was turning inside out okay um so what's
what the car I'm a car guy I love
gears so it's a Nissan 370Z a sweet nice
car okay and what your
model uh 2019 okay all right cool and
what's the car you're currently driving
worth um it's
$133,000 okay all right um what's your
income
trajectory uh when would you be making
90 uh
potentially maybe five years from now
whoa so I'm you're gonna get $10,000
raise over five
years uh well I'm I'm I'm projecting a
promotion and then um how the military
works when I move oh you're in the
military okay correct okay now I
understand okay yeah that would be more
reasonable in the military most people
are going to make a lot more in five
years than a $10,000 race I'm just
that's why I went right right yeah okay
well I mean here's the
thing I love cars okay I drove here
today in my Raptor I I I love big
engines uh I like things that make noise
I'm redneck I want a loud Muffler um all
that right uh but the stupid things go
down in
value Like a Rock that's where Chevy got
that like a rock okay they go down in
value and that includes that sweet
Nissan you're talking about and that
includes my sweet Raptor they go down in
value so if you're going to build wealth
you have to keep as small an amount and
as possible going into things that go
down in value so consequently we find
millionaires driving very conservative
used
cars until they until they've got you
know substantial money um and the one of
the guidelines that George that we've
developed here is to not have more than
half your annual income tied up in
things that have motor and wheels so
adding up all of your little toys with
motors and
wheels uh do does it add up to more than
half your annual income because if it
does you probably got too much in things
going down in value while you're trying
to build wealth does that make sense to
you
mathematically yeah yes like I mean it'd
be like $45,000 total yeah and you make
80 and so you're over
half yeah okay so um sweet car sweet car
and you got the cash if you do it you
can do it I mean you can afford it
obviously but the warning is that you're
putting money in the wrong places if you
want to be
wealthy got it I mean the way you know
someone's going to stay middle class is
when they have two very nice cars that
are obvious five6 $700 payments sitting
in front of a middle class
house exactly 100% those people are
going to stay middle class until they
break that habit it's just a it's a huge
indicator yeah and the other thing to
think about Micah is you got another set
of insurance premiums to pay more
maintenance and repair and so right now
as you're in the military I don't know
how much driving you're doing on these
vehicles but I would consider those
because it is a toy and so this is not
going to crush you if you do it but
we're just saying it may not be the time
yeah I
I as much as I completely grasp what
you're doing and I I and you know that's
a great car I I as the guy on the radio
that tells you to do things to become
wealthy I'm going to tell you don't do
it I'm gonna tell you wait a later when
you've got more money and you're in a
better financial position to do it
you've got the money to pay cash if you
do it's not going to bankrupt you that
is not what we're saying we're not being
melodramatic I just wanted when I went
broke when I was younger older slightly
older than you I I I made the decision
I'm going to do things that cause me not
to be broke anymore and I'm going to
identify what broke people do I'm not
going to do that I'm going to identify
what rich people do and I am going to do
that and you know what we discover Tom
Stanley found it first in 1992 when he
did did a book called Millionaire Next
Door we discovered it again when we did
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in North America
10,167 of them we interviewed we did not
find fancy cars it was Honda Toyota
four-year-old used cars nothing that's
going to turn heads at the stoplight
yeah if they're millionaires now if
you're a billionaire it's different you
can drive whatever you want right but a
billion is a thousand million it's a
different thing scales yeah millionaires
don't have that they don't have Jets
millionaires don't have seven cars uh
millionaires don't you know that
millionaires just have some money is all
and and they have generally speaking
conservative but reasonable Lifestyles
and so we tell folks not to buy a brand
new car until you have a net worth of of
a million dollars if you do have a car
you should sell it if it violates those
things and or if you can't get it and
all your Consumer Debt paid off within
two years because of the stupid car and
so if you got like a $50,000 car you
make $60,000 a year you need to sell it
and you need to you know get rid of this
$1,100 payment it just choking you to
death it loses 60% of the value in 5
years these new cars it's brutal we went
through a period of time on this show
about a decade ago where the answer to
every question was sell the car sell the
car it was the sell the car show create
your free every doll budget today
the simplest way to budget for your life